[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est Bruno
tertray bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on est ravi de
vous recevoir Bruno tertr directeur
adjoint de la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique expert associé à
l'Intitut Montaigne auteur de ce livre
sorti il y a quelques jours Pax Atomica
théorie pratique et limite de la
dissuasion C aux éditions ODIL Jacob on
va évidemment parler cette question du
nucléaire mais d'abord un petit mot sur
l'actualité d'hier sur la guerre en
Ukraine puisque les 27 États européens
se sont mis d'accord le Premier ministre
hongrois Victor Orban a levé son véteau
dès le début du sommet ce qui était un
peu une surprise accord sur 50 milliards
d'euros d'Aid débloqué pour l'Ukraine
sur 4 ans est-ce que pour vous cette
nature a changé le cours de la guerre
pas forcément à court terme mais ce qui
est très important pour les ukrainien
c'est de savoir que l'Europe les
soutient dans la durée et c'est
important parce que c'est c'est donc
pour le budget communautaire de
2024-227 et donc c'est la promesse d'une
assistance à l'Ukraine attention on
parle pas d'assistance militaire là on
parle d'assistance à la reconstruction à
la mise en place de l'État de droit aux
réformes et cetera et donc c'est
j'allais dire c'est d'abord et avant
tout important psychologiquement mais la
guerre ça se gagne aussi dans les têtes
ouais ce qu'a dit aussi peut-être ce qu'
a voulu dire Emmanuel Macron quand il
dit hier à sa conférence de presse à
l'issue du sommet la Russie ne peut pas
compter sur une quelconque fatigue des
Européens dans leur soutien l'Ukraine ça
veut dire que c'était aussi un message à
Vladimir Poutine qui misait peut-être
sur un essoufflement de l'aide
occidentale alors il mise sur deux
choses ou sur trois d'abord un
essoufflement de l'Ukraine un
essoufflement des Européens et un
essoufflement des Américains il n'a pas
gagné sur le premier tableau ni sur le
deuxème il mise encore sans doute sur le
3ème qui est l'élection bien sûr de
Donald Trump aux États-Unis et c'est
pour cela que les Ukrainiens qui ont cet
événement bien sûr comme nous tous en
ligne de mire savent qu'ils doivent
faire quelque chose d'important avant
que ce profil l'arrivée possible d'un
nouveau président il pourrait changer le
cours de la guerre si Donald Trump
revient au pouvoir je dirais que s'il y
a bien un événement qui pourrait
infléchir les choses dans un sens
défavorable à l'Ukraine et favorable à
la Russie c'est bien sûr une
interruption totale éventuelle de l'aide
d'américaine si Donald Trump était élu
mais attention il se passerait encore du
temps l'aide ça s'interrompt pas c'est
pas un robinet qu'on qu'on allume ou
qu'on qu'on ouvre ou qu'on ferme donc
tout ce ça tout ceci nous projette vers
2025 dans tous les cas les Ukrainiens
savent qu'il faut qu'ils avancent entre
guillemets dans tous les sens du terme
en 2024 on va venir sur le cours de la
guerre mais l'Union européenne alors
elle a donné cette TER cette aide mais
dans le même temps parce que vous
parliez de l'aide militaire elle a
reconnu qu'elle ne pourrait pas livrer 1
million d'obus c'était l'objectif qui
était fixé est-ce que ça montre quand
même qu'il y a certaines faiblesses du
côté de l'Union européenne oui vous vous
souvenez que qu'Emmanuel Macron parlait
il y a déjà presque 2 ans de d'économie
de guerre la France ne s'est pas mise en
économie de guerre d'ailleurs nous ne
sommes pas en guerre euh mais la Pologne
un petit peu l'Allemagne très peu et
finalement on a trop tardé à adapter nos
industrie et à faire suffisamment de
commande à ces industries et pas la
France pour vous parce que le ministre
des Armées il dit que c'est parce qu'on
s'est mis en économie de guerre qu'on
peut livrer par exemple les qu'on peut
produire les 78 canons César vous dites
non c'est pas totalement faux on a
adapté beaucoup de choses mais trop peu
trop lentement non la France l'industrie
de défense française a énormément évolué
euh depuis 2 ans mais elle ne s'est pas
mise en économie de guerre donc nous
faisons beaucoup de choses c'est bien et
c'est vrai que depuis depuis un an nous
avons beaucoup avancé on fait tout ce
qu'on peut mais c'est évidemment pas
assez pour les Ukrainiens ouais et ce
puisque vous parlez de l'aide militaire
selon les les chiffres qu'on a la France
est un petit peu à la traain en Europe
540 millions d'euros c'est très loin
derrière l'Allemagne le Royaume-Uni même
la Pologne on parle évidemment pas des
États-Unis est-ce que ces classements
ils ont un sens ou est-ce que la France
apporte une aide sans le dire on n'est
pas dans une salle de classe les les
classements n'ont pas beaucoup de sens
parce que il il dépendent énormément des
critères qui sont utilisés aide civile
aide militaire aide immédiate aide aide
à long terme engagement ou livraison
effective et puis surtout en général ces
classements ils ne prennent pas en
compte la qualité de ce qui est de ce
qui est envoyé militairement parfois des
matériel un peu moins cher peuvent faire
la différence donc je crois qu'il faut
c'est un critère comme un autre ce class
ce fameux classement de Kill mais je
comprends aussi l'agassement de
Sébastien lecnu lorsqu'on se réfère trop
systématiquement à ce seul classement
pour dire la France est à la traain ouis
le 24 février ça fait 2 ans que les la
réussie à attaquer l'Ukraine c'est un
conflit qui est parti pour durer encore
longtemps surelon vous écoutez un
conflit qui dure 2 ans et qui est
enquisté de de cette manière il a toutes
les chances de durer encore assez
longtemps en même temps dans les guerres
il y a parfois des moments où il y a des
tournants il y a des bascules parfois de
manière un petit peu inattendu et donc
le fait que c'est duré 2 ans ne veut pas
dire nécessairement que ça durera 2 ans
de plus on va parler du risque nucléire
he c'est l'objet de votre livre je le
disais est-ce que vous vous croyez
encore à une escalade à une escalade du
conflit en
général vous avez l'air de dire que j'y
croyais donc écoutez moi ce que je
constate c'est que du côté occidental
mais aussi du côté russe on a finalement
avec 2 ans de recul été assez prudent
quant à la manière dont on a cherché à
escalader le conflit justement et c'est
justement l'un des objets du livre c'est
le rôle de la dissuasion nucléire à
savoir que c'est quelque chose qui borne
l'horizon de la conflictualité de part
et d'autre si la Russie attaque et
envahit l'Ukraine c'est à l'ombre de son
parapluie nucléaire si elle ne s'attaque
pas aux Occidentaux qui aident l'Ukraine
c'est aussi parce que ceux-ci ont l'arme
nucléaire et si nous de notre côté on se
limite à une assistance indirecte les
forces des pays de l'OTAN
n'interviennent pas en Ukraine c'est
aussi parce que la Russie est une
puissance nucléaire donc même sans
emploi de l'arme nucléaire et bien cette
arme étend son nombre d'une certaine
manière autour de ce conflit très
clairement est-ce qu' aujourd'hui le
risque nucléaire de la part de la Russie
est écartée il serait raisonnable de
l'écarter totalement à partir du moment
où une puissance nucléaire est est
engagée dans un conflit de haute
intensité et que à quelques centines de
kilomètres il y a deux trois autres
puissances nucléaires on peut pas dire
que le risque nucléaire n'existe pas en
revanche je fais partie de ceux assez
RAR je dois dire qui dès le 24 février
2022 ont dit le risque nucléaire est
minime non pas inexistant mais minime et
lorsque l'on regarde bien le
comportement de la Russie dans ce
domaine malgré des déclarations
incendiaires dans les médias malgré les
redomentades de certains responsables
politiques tels que l'ancien président
medvedef ce qu'on voit c'est que dans
les faits dans les faits d'abord Poutine
et les deux trois personnes pas plus qui
sont autorisé à en parler ont un langage
mesuré dans dans ce domaine et surtout
le plus important c'est qu'on n pas vu
de choses inhabituelles du côté de
l'arsenal nucléaire russe si Poutine
avait vraiment voulu nous faire peur en
agitant la carte nucléaire il avait
beaucoup de manières différentes de le
faire il ne l'a pas fait donc je
continue à penser que jusqu'à présent en
tout cas il préfère il projeter essayer
de donner l'image d'une puissance
nucléaire responsable la Russie agit de
manière totalement irresponsable dans
tous les domaines mais je dois dire
qu'il est difficile de la qualifié
aujourd'hui sur ce domainelà de pays
totalement irresponsable ouais mais vous
le croyez capable d'appuyer sur sur le
bouton un jour ou pas la la dissuasion
suppose que on soit persuadé que l'autre
pourrait un jour comme vous dites
appuyer sur le bouton donc si on ne
croit pas l'autre capable il n'y a pas
de dissuasion de même si nous étions en
Russie quelqu'un poserait peut-être la
question est-ce que vous croyez Emmanuel
Macron capable d'appuyer sur le bouton
peu importe ce que je pense ou ce que
vous pensez c'est ce qui se passe dans
le dialogue dissuasif c'est justement un
jeu de perception entre chef d'État et
de gouvernement il faut que des deux
côtés on soit persuadé que l'autre
pourrait appuyer sur le bouton dans des
circonstances extrêmes j'ai assez peu de
doute sur la le le scénario dans lequel
Poutine effectivement serait capable de
le faire ouais c'est c'est ce que
signifie le titre de votre livre Pax
Atomica que finalement la dissuasion
nucléaire est garante de paix garante
d'une certaine paix pas de la paix dans
le monde évidemment nous sommes dans un
monde dans lequel les conflits sont sont
sont très importants mais vous avez
remarqué que j'ai mis un point
d'interrogation euh après le titre ça
veut dire est-ce qu'il y a vraiment une
forme de Pai nucléaire et après un
réexamen de cette très vieille
problématique que je ne suis pas le
premier à à à analyser j'en conclus que
oui euh la l'arme nucléaire a très
probablement c'est pas des
démonstrations mathématiques mais
contribué à l'absence de conflit
militaires direct entre grandes
puissances et entre pays qui sont dotés
de de l'armatonique ça ne veut pas pas
dire que la diffation ne peut pas
échouer elle peut échouer comme toute
activité humaine mais il faut bien se
rendre compte que plus de 80 ans sans
conflit entre grande puissance c'est
quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel au
regard de l'histoire des siècles passés
ma conclusion c'est que oui l'arbre
nucléaire a été l'une des clés principal
sinon la principale de de cet état de
fait est-ce que ça durera éternellement
non peut-être pas est-ce que le Paris
nucléaire est suffisamment intéressant
en terme de coût efficacité pour qu'on
puisse continuer à le faire oui à mon
sens la réponse est oui alors est-ce que
ça ça durait éternellement ça ça m'amène
à vous poser une question sur l'Iran
est-ce que si l'Iran qui cherche à avoir
l'âme nucléaire réussissait à l'obtenir
la PAX Atomica serait menacée en partie
l'Iran depuis 20 ans s'approche du seuil
nucléaire il s'en approche de plus en
plus lentement parce qu'il sait qu'il
faut pas aller trop loin mais si jamais
l'Iran devait se doter de cette arme ça
serait un échec terrible pour l'ensemble
de ce qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale c'est c'est-à-dire
essentiellement les grandes puissances
les cinq y compris la Chine et la Russie
qui ont négocié avec l'Iran ça serait un
échec terrible pour l'Europe pour les
États-Unis et pour Israël donc ça serait
pas un échec de la dissuision nucléaire
mais ça serait un échec de toute les les
menaces dissuasives qu'on a essayé
d'exercer vis-à-vis de l'Iran donc ça
serait un séisme géostratégique de
première grandeur il n'est pas certain
que l'Iran aille jusqu'à franchir le
seuil mais en même temps on n pas
beaucoup vu pays dans l'histoire qui
sont allés jusque- là et qui ont
abandonné donc tout reste ouvert je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les Israéliens
surtout après le 7 octobre surtout après
le 7 octobre estim qu'ils ne peuvent pas
se permettre de vivre avec un Iran qui
aurait la capacité de le détruire
physiquement mais en même temps je pense
que les Américains non plus autrement
dit je pense que le seuil d'intervention
américaine serait probablement le même
que l'intervention israélienne donc
c'est mais ce qui veut dire est-ce que
si l'Iran est au seuil d'avoir la bombe
qu'Israël et que les États-Unis pour
intervenir employer des emploirer en
tout cas des moyens militaires pour
empêcher l'Iran d'acquérir cette bome
seulement oui mais seulement s'ils
étaient persuadés avec du renseignement
en béton que l'Iran est en train de
fabriquer un engin nucléaire
opérationnel on n est absolument pas là
l'Iran a presque suffisamment de matière
ficile pour au moins un un engin
pourrait le faire en quelques jours même
mais il lui resterait des mois sans
doute peut-être même une année pour
fabriquer l'engin lui-même est-ce que ça
pourrait faire discrètement ou pas c'est
bien là la question pour pour revenir à
votre question de départ je dirais que
si les ran se dotait de l'armatomique et
respectait les codes de la dissuasion ça
veut pas dire que l'ensemble
de l'ensemble de l'édifice nucléaire
construit depuis 1945 ne serait pas
totalement ébranlé pour autant ce qui
serait ébranlé en revanche c'est ce
qu'on appelle le régime de non
prolifération nucléaire puisque l'Iran
s'est interdit lui-même de fabriquer
cette arme et donc en principe ne peut
pas le faire légalement et si l'Iran
donnait l'exemple peut-être peut-être
que d'autres seraient tentés de le faire
également sur la Biélorussie le 16
janvier borussie a annoncé une
modification de sa doctrine militaire
visant à placer sous son propre
commandement les armes nucléaires
tactiques russes censé avoir été déployé
sur son territoire qu'est-ce que ça
change une telle décision quels sont les
enjeux alors d'abord personne ne sait ou
alors s'il y a du renseignement je je
n'y ai pas accès s'il y a effectivement
des armes nucléaires russes aujourd'hui
en Biélorussie il y a les
infrastructures il y a semble-t-il de
l'entraînement de certaines forces
biélorusses qui pourra emporté des armes
russes mais personne ne peut vous dire
avec certitude aujourd'hui si
effectivement les armes russes en
Biélorussie le plus important dans cette
affaire c'est c'est l'aspect politique
en disant je suis désormais un allié de
la Russie capable d'emporter ses armes
nucléaires la Biélorussie s'inscrit
encore davantage que par le passé dans
le système de défense russe et en fait
finalement tout c toute cette affaire de
nucléaire en biéorussie c'est d'abord et
avant tout le symbole de l'insertion
presque total désormais de ce pays dans
l'orbite l'orbite de défense russe mais
sinon sur le principe on nous retrouve
une situation qu'on a connu au temps du
pacte de Varsovie à savoir qu'il y avait
des armées du PACT de Varsovie qui
pouvaient emporter des des armes
soviétiques on retrouve aussi le
mécanisme qui aujourd'hui existe dans le
cadre de l'OTAN à savoir qu'il y a des
pays européens qui peuvent emporter des
armes américaines donc ça ne change pas
la donne militaire ou stratégique
fondamentalement mais sur le plan
politique c'est un c'est c'est un peu
plus qu'un symbole quelles sont les les
limites de la dissuasion nucléaire alors
les limites de la dissuasion c'est ce
sont les limites de toute activité
humaine à savoir il faut se comprendre
il faut connaître l'adversaire
comprendre l'adversaire et savoir
dialoguer avec lui de manière ouverte ou
par par des des gestes militaires d'une
manière qui garantissent que de chaque
côté on sait jusqu'où ne pas aller trop
loin donc forcément j'allais dire il y a
des limites intrinsèque à la dissuasion
ce ce ce à quoi je j'arrive comme
conclusion c'est que la dissuasion est
probablement plus solide que ce qu'on a
souvent voulu dire dans le pas le passé
et que lorsqu'on réexamine les crises
qui ont eu lieu ou dans lesquelles
parfois effectivement l'emploi de l'arme
nucléaire a été envisagé depuis 1945 et
bien on remarque que finalement au
dernier moment les dirigeants politiques
et militaires ont été prudents et ont
reculé et que quelque part dans cette
escalade qui mène à l'emploi de l'arme
nucléaire C escalade théorique ben
finalement la dernière marche est
peut-être la plus haute et donc cette
retenue elle elle est un acquis
fondamental de de l'âge nucléaire et
elle me semble encore exister
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle le nucléaire ça fait peur même
au possesseurs de l'arme nucléaire
est-ce que ça veut dire que cette
dissuasion nucléaire nous préserve d'une
guerre mondiale ou pas ça nous préserve
en grande partie très probablement de du
l'escalade entre puissance nucléaire par
exemple la Russie la la Chine et les
États-Unis à propos de Taiwan qui irait
jusqu'à l'affrontement total autrement
dit cela réduit considérablement sans
l'anéantir totalement la probabilité
d'un très grand affrontement à l'échelle
planétaire je suis prudent je suis pas
en train de vous dire que tout ça on
n'est pas dans l'absolu mais ça réduit
très
significativement la probabilité d'un
enchaînement de circonstances qui nous
mènerait à un très grand conflit de type
de ce qu'on a connu au 20e siècle dans
votre livre vous faites le ConA sur neuf
pays possédant l'arme nucléaire trois
sont des démocraties matures les
États-Unis le Royaume-Uni la France deux
sont des démocraties imparfaites Israël
et l'Inde on va revenir d'ailleurs sur
le cas d'Israël 1 un régime hybride le
Pakistan et 3 États autoritaires la
Russie la Chine la Corée du Nord c'est
pas très très rassurant écoutez ce que
je voulais dire par là c'est qu'on ne
peut pas associer l'arme nucléaire à un
type de régime politique c'est ni l'arme
des démocraties ni l'arme des dictatures
c'est c'est ça qui est c'est ça qui est
intéressant les catégories que j'utilise
c'est des catégories de la de la science
politique mais c'est peu importe c'est
pour montrer qu'on ne peut pas associer
l'ARM nucléaire à un type de régime ce
qui est certain c'est que si ça protège
les démocraties ça protège aussi les
dictatures et bien souvent pour un pays
comme la Corée du Nord par exemple c'est
c'est la
garantie de survie hélas d'un régime
parmi les les pires de la planète et
c'est bien pour cela que la Corée du
Nord a voulu se doter de cette arme
c'est pour protéger son régime politique
et son pays tel qu'il a été construit
dans tous les sens du terme parceon ne
s'attaque pas à un régime si autorit
qu'il soit s'il a l'arme nucléaire on ne
on ne s'attaque pas frontalement de
manière directe et militaire à un état
qui est doté de l'arme nucléaire on peut
s'y attaquer de manière indirecte on
peut avoir des guerres limitées qui
impliquent un état doté de l'arme
nucléaire mais on va pas le l'attaquer
jusqu'à la destruction je donne un
exemple qui est souvent cité d'ailleurs
dans la dans les débats par ceux qui
estiment que la dision nucléaire ça ne
marche pas ils disent en 1973 euh Israël
a été attaqué par l'Égypte et la Syrie
sauf qu'on sait maintenant que justement
l'Égypte était bien conscient du statut
nucléaire d'Israël et n'a pas attaqué
autre chose que les territoires qui
étaient occupés par Israël autrement dit
le cœur du territoire israélien n'a pas
été touché et les Égyptiens savaient
très bien justement jusqu'où ne pas
aller trop loin pourquoi Israël n'
puisquon en parle n'a jamais confirmé
avoir l'arme nucléaire selon vous alors
d'abord il y a il y a un aspect
essentiel c'est que pour Israël c'est
pas une arme politique c'est une arme de
survie le statut nucléaire n'est pas
important pour Israël au contraire de ce
qui est le cas pour la Corée du Nord
l'Inde ou même la France pour la France
c'est d'abord une affirmation
d'indépendance vis-à-vis des États-Unis
ça veut dire à la face du monde nous ne
dépendons pas de l'Amérique pour notre
survie pour Israël la dimension
politique est totalement absente c'est
une arme de survie deuxième raison les
Israéliens sont au fond quelque part un
petit peu mal à l'aise vis-à-vis de la
dissuision nucléaire parce que surtout à
l'époque où les armes étaient très peu
précises ils savaient très bien que de
leur côté si jamais ils devaient
recourir à cette extrémité ça serait
très probablement provoquer des dommages
aux populations civiles extrêmement
importants or c'est un pays qui a bien
sûr la mémoire de la Choa et donc l'idée
de dire nous pourrions nous-mêmes
provoquer non pas un génocide même si ce
terme fait écho à des polémiques
contemporaines mais quelque chose qui
conduirait à la destruction de
population ou de villes entières c'est
quelque chose que je peux en témoigner
personnellement j'ai beaucoup discuté de
ces sujets en en Israël c'est quelque
chose qui met les israélien on le
comprend euh assez mal à l'aise troisème
raison c'est que les Israéliens savent
que s'ils devaient avouer leur puissance
nucléaire et bien cela donnerait des
arguments à ceux qui dans leur
environnement régional y compris l'Iran
d'ailleurs euh voudrai faire de même
voilà pour toutes ces raisons Israël
n'en parle pas même si l'arsenal
israélien comme celui de l'Inde et du
Pakistan n'est pas illégal au garde du
droit international puisque ce pays ne
s'est jamais engagé contrairement à
l'Iran par exemple à ne pas se doter de
l'armes nucléaire mais est-ce que du
coup c'est une donnée à prendre en
compte dans le conflit actuel avec le
Hamas pas tellement et justement les les
tragiques événements du du 7 octobre
nous montrent que la dissuation
nucléaire ne n'empêche pas tout on le
savait déjà mais hélas ça a été
tragiquement confirmé et ce qui est
intellectuellement intéressant dans
cette tragédie c'est que cela montre
aussi que un état peut subir une
blessure qu'il estime être de l'ordre de
l' entiel puisque c'est comme ça que le
7 octobre est vécu en en Israël et
qu'une attaque très significative sur
son territoire reconnu peut exister et
qu'un massacre peut avoir lieu sans que
le nucléaire n'y puisse grand-chose car
le nucléaire fondamentalement c'est un
dialogue de chefs d'État et de
gouvernement face à des des menaces
plutôt classiques donc cela révèle aussi
justement les limites de la disuasion
nucléaire mais c'est pas une garantie
absolue de sécurité non mais ça n'a
jamais été fait pour ça est-ce que ça ça
coûte cher d'AV avir l'â nucléaire et
est-ce que ça demande des
investissements réguliers ça coûte cher
ça c'est un c'est un jugement de valeur
le nucléaire par sa puissance j'allais
dire coûte moins cher par destruction
que le les armements classiques ou
conventionnels mais ces calculs n'ont
pas beaucoup de sens la question c'est
combien est-ce qu'un État est prêt à
mettre pour garantir sa survie sur le
moyen terme et sur le long terme parce
que ce sont des investissements très
longs les sous-marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engin par exemple entre le
moment où la décision est prise et le
moment où le sous-marin est est retiré
du service c'est plusieurs décennies
donc c'est ce sont des investissements
de très long terme il faut pas négliger
non plus le bénéfice de la dissuasion
nucléaire sur l'ensemble de l'appareil
de défense c'est particulièrement
important pour un pays comme la France
qui a une dissuasion qui est presque
totalement autonome on a presque tout
fait tout seul et ça ça veut dire que ça
a tiré vers le haut notre industrie
notre industrie de défense notamment
dans le domaine des hautes technologies
et il y a plein de ramifications
positive sur l'industrie pas seulement
de défense d'ailleurs mais par exemple
sur on a fait une machine extraordinaire
dans les environs de Bordeaux pour
simuler le fonctionnement des armes
nucléaires ben il y a eu il y a il y a
autour ce qu'on appelle la route des
lasers puisque tout ça est basé sur des
lasers et donc ça ça ça a permis de
développer d'encourager le développement
de ce tout ce qui est optique et
optronique en France donc il y a des
bénéfices de l'autre côté ça coûte cher
oui c'est près de c'est près de 6
milliards par an actuellement euh pour
quelques années donc c'est pas du tout
négligeable euh c'est un peu plus de 20
% c'est quasiment 1/4 de notre
investissement de défense pas du budget
de la défense en entier mais notre
investissement de défense c'est très
significatif mais ça aussi des
desavantages induit on va on va revenir
aux États-Unis pour terminer on parlait
tout à l'heure des possibles
conséquences de sur la guerre en Ukraine
d'une élection de Donald Trump est-ce
que s'il revient au pouvoir à la fin de
l'année ça changerait des choses sur le
plan justement du nucléaire de la
dissuasion nucléaire oui ça changerait
deux choses la première que c'est que
Donald Trump avec tous ses défauts ils
sont
gigantesques il a au moins un avantage
c'est que c'est un bon
dissuadeur ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui par ses
soures d'humeur par son aspect
imprévisible et finalement quelqu'un qui
n'est pas mauvais pour déstabiliser le
les adversaires potentiels parceon se
dit lui il peut appuyer sur le bouton
alors il pourrait le faire et puis
surtout il il parle d'une manière qui
est assez surprenante et je me souviens
très bien que la Corée du Nord
manifestement en 2017 ne savait pas pas
trop sur quel pied dansé face à Donald
Trump c'est le seul point positif le le
l'énorme problème c'est que bien sûr si
les Européens découvraient que Donald
Trump du jour au lendemain abandonnait
cette garantie de sécurité que
l'Amérique offre à l'Europe ou donne à
l'Europe plutôt qu'offre parce que c'est
pas gratuit depuis
1945 il y aurait bien sûr des
conséquences à entirer sur le plan de la
dissuasion nucléaire est-ce que la
France et la Grande-Bretagne seraient
prêt à compenser
cette perte de garantie nucléaire
américaine c'est un questionnement qui
est déjà ancien puisqueon on se posait
déjà la question pendant le premier
mandat de Donald Trump mais c'est un
questionnant extrêmement important
auquel la France d'ailleurs réfléchit
déjà ça veut dire que les les Européens
est-ce que déjà aujourd'hui les
Européens ils peuvent compter sur le
nucléaire américain la question c'est
est-ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils peuvent
compter dessus est-ce que la Russie et
les autres pensent qu'ils peuvent
compter dessus la réponse c'est
probablement oui mais je me souviens au
tout de ma carrière d'avoir eu des
discussions avec d'anciens responsables
militaires soviétiques qui étaient très
intéressante parce que elle elle
révélait que les Soviétiques estimaient
les Américains assez prévisibles et
pensaient que les Français étaient un
peu plus imprévisibles et étaaiit
peut-être parce qu'ils sont sur le sol
européen justement B était peut-être
plus pront à appuyer sur le sur la
gâchette nucléaire si j'ose dire s'il y
avait eu une guerre en Europe merci
Bruno TER TR merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité pour cet entretien je
remonte votre livre Pax Atomica théorie
pratique et limite de la dissuasion et
puis on va regarder un autre de vos
livres la guerre des mondes merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été not on pe
lire les deux dans l'ordre ça se suit
assez bien ah ben voilà d'abord la
guerre des mondes et après pas Tom on
invite les téléspectateurs à le faire
merci beaucoup Bruno d'avoir été notre
invité pass au club des territoires